ciao ragazzi ben tornati nella puntata
di cucina buttata ogni volta alla fine
di un video vi faccio una domanda che
cosa posso fare nel video successivo e
spesso mi è arrivato un commento prova a
fare i pancakes i giapponesi quelli di
un pochino soffici e alti partiamo dal
presupposto che non sono un fan dei
pancake sì mi piacciono a me sembra
sempre una botta di burro e vita e che
quelli giapponesi mi hanno sempre messo
un po di timore questi cosi alti non lo
so mi sembra che affondi denti
all'interno della spugna non lo so non
me la sento per alla fine mi son detto
provaci se questo che ci hanno chiesto
le persone rispetto alla parola che è
dato che l'hanno chiesto fallo ho
cercato una ricetta che potesse
convincere all'interno del mondo del web
è quella che ho trovato che realtà è
anche quella più popolare è fatta da
benedetta fatto in casa benedetta che ho
avuto il piacere di conoscere e che è
una donna stupenda dolcissima
serenissimo e quindi ho detto una
persona così carina e buona dovrà per
forza fare cose buone benedetta se
mostra esperimento mi viene da mehlman
ca bando alle ciance per fare i japanese
fluffy pancake nutella easy residui per
chi in inglese lo mettiamo anche lui il
titolo in inglese japanese fluffy
pancake suite nutella by benedetta così
si doveva detto questo per fare i
pancakes flap i pancakes japanese con
nutella hanno bisogno di due uova 25
grammi di zucchero 20 millilitri tv
latte mazza la miseria 40 grammi di
farina manitoba c'è un problema questo
qui non è manitoba questa qui è una
farina normale perché a quanto pare in
questo periodo di crisi da cofit a
manitoba è come se fosse non lo so una
mascherina non so perché tutti cerchino
manitoba quindi non ce l'avevo la
manitoba ma questo non mi fermerà dalle
pare i pancakes avete la manitoba bella
per voi altrimenti
tri g di lievito per dolci burro per
imburrare e infine lei l'unica
meravigliosa non tenda sentono moratti
non starò un pallone
che c'ha rotto li voglio divertire devo
dire questa cosa io amo amo amo i dolci
giapponese li trovo interessanti li
trovo figli ma i pancakes giapponesi uno
dei mai provati non mi fanno paura un
pochino quell'altezza quella roba lì
iniziamo io mi è capitato a settat e
dovrò fare l'ipo gobbo per prima cosa
avremmo bisogno di una ciotola delle due
uova e di una ciotolina più piccola
all'interno della quale metteremo i
tuorli noi quindi riapriamo li buttiamo
dentro mammamia scoliosi che io sono
sempre stato bravo da piccolino a
dividere queste cose sarà che divide i
miei genitori
uno è mai fermato ok e due comunque no
ho parlato ma che mi faccio i miei mai
che mi facci che mai che mi faccio i
cazzi miei
mamma non l'ho mai detto poi secondo me
sv montiamo comunque con poco poco poco
tuorlo non succede niente solo
strategicamente non dovreste avere
quello però amen
eccomi qui sempre gobbo avrà dicevo
quale sto per fare una delle cose mi
diverte di più cucina sono un sacco di
pasticceri quando montano l'album è come
farò adesso io fondamentalmente
finiscono lo zucchero da aggiungere
quindi i nostri 25 gr i venti grammi
netti ciclo sono prodotto all'inizio in
concomitanza con la neve degli albumi
s'è capito che ho detto non lo so quindi
io inizio ed è un modo anche per avere
debba stare rossetti si crea un modo
anche per avere gli albumi più fermi
perché la base la meringa
benedetta spero di rendermi orgoglioso
come si stanno montando a neve gli
albumi proviamoci riproviamoci perché
licenziamo mani fi
rimettiamoci sotto sempre questa bella
inquadratura orribile e uova ritroviamo
gioco al contrario ragazzi lo sapete che
può sempre fatto schifo io fare questo
procedimento questa l'ho capita certo
noi a tempi si loda s'imbroda a posto
sbattiamo con 25 grammi di zucchero
[Musica]
ok sì sì sì sì sì sì sì direi di mettere
il composto tutto quanto dentro la
terrina di prima canova composto è
quando monticolo rossonero tipo più
lucido può essere a questo punto
aggiunge abituali
andiamo alcuni non hanno consigliato di
mettermi un ago però sulla testa in modo
da rendere tutto più facile
potrebbe funzionare secondo piano molto
morbidi e questi muoiono in due secondi
ogni volta che ho a che fare con cose
che si montano e venezia sono ammalerò
mi viene l'ansia unica o sempre ora di
smontarle sono ancora peggio
andiamo tutti a questo composto bisogna
aggiungere i 20 millilitri latte poco
alla volta l'ente mini vedere come fa
troppo alla volta ok sor settimane passo
al 7 poi queste mi sembrano anche dosi
decenti non per fare 2000 pancake ma per
fare una roba tipo terreni come le fa
lei che cretino ragazzi ho preso oltre
alla nutella lambro detto delle cose e
decorative che tu dici ammazza che sei
diventato omosessuale no ero tipo
fragole mirtilli lamponi e quindi credo
che utilizzano anche quelli per rendere
il tutto ancora più carino mi raccomando
la che in questi casi con la farina
setacciare sempre la rottura di pound
finita solo accordo fosse per me la
metterei così quindi se facciamo ed a
mettere da parte e incorporiamo anche
qui molta delicatezza
sono chance the woman piano ce la
facciamo più pacchiano a sano e va
lontano dice a mio nonno dice ancora
viva grazie al cielo
l'imposta si sta addensando rimane molto
cremoso
non so quanto possa mantenere la forma
solitamente dovrebbe farlo e ne sono
rimasti due grammi di farina che ci
aggiungo così incorpora un corpo
incorpora senza paura incorpora
incorpora insieme incorpora incorpora
incontrato e incontra ok a posto hanno
riempito per lui non è tutto fatto sono
tre grandi lievito che faccio
così se ne sono più di 3 grammi ma
decisamente più di 3 grammi sto per fare
delle specie di panettoni e gonfi come i
testicoli di tutti coloro che stanno
passando questa quarantena in casa
nonché quelli di tutte le persone vanno
comunque lavorare siano meno sgonfi
nonché quelli del genere umano
in teoria sono particolarmente minuti ok
ragazzi ho fatto è arrivato il momento
del secondo step la cottura la padella
si riscalda nel frattanto uno di burro
andiamo a quel punto con uno scottex
scusate sembra un videogioco in prima
persona a asciugare leggermente in
realtà da pannella ma dovevano avere
troppo duro andiamo alla ricerca
all'interno di questo casino presto qui
tutto 88 ciao
prendiamo versiamo una padella i suoi
sono diversi continuo a ribadire che i
suoi sono diversi a questo punto turista
del siamo o no no si stanno unendo
quelli di nato addio invece ho provato
ho sbagliato scusami bene sopra no ma
guarda lì somigli a riprendermi da solo
sto fan casinò come dobbiamo fare adesso
è prendere dell'acqua subito cucchiaio
d'acqua
lo vedete lo vedete lo vedete e metterlo
di lato di lato
di lato a questo punto veloci offriamo
tutto quanto quindi l'acqua inizierà a
bollire dentro vedete anche a creare una
cappa di vapore teoricamente questa roba
dovrebbe cucinarli non lo so e non mi
sento tranquillo la cosa però che vedo e
che stanno lievitando un sacco guardia 4
ciccioni non so se lo vedete voi due
sono diventati fratelli gemelli poi li
stacchiamo sempre un décolleté con lui
guardatelo è delizioso ma noi e lo
stress momento la cottura trovo in un
momento difficile questo quasi staff
cards e come sotto l'ho fatto
ripartiamo lo non avete visto però
aspetta non vi faccio vedere tutto ciò
che immaginate che stai andando tutto
bene
portatemi un po di fortuna ti prego non
ci credono tanto un altro che l'acqua
così nel dubbio allora guardateli non
sono tantissimi avrei potuto fare meglio
ma guardate che bello che lui
quelli sono i gemellini ma guardate che
belli lasciano andare nel frattempo
prepara un piazzamento mai chiesto
piatto signori non voglio parlare troppo
velocemente ma io da quando sto in
quarantena io lavoro meglio cm enrico
gianmarco in realtà mi rallentavano mi
rallentavano quei due morti che stavano
lì e mi mian ed etico anarchico minime
invece no così portate nella libertà non
mi vedete anche più sano di mente da
quando sto da solo io sto benissimo sto
benissimo faccio le cose fanno tutte
persone stabilmente leggo guardo film
parlo con la mia tavoletta ilva terra ti
faccio vedere sti pancake sono belli
altini caldissimi arrivato il momento
della decorazione questa inquadratura
che non ci fa capire niente ci fa
sembrare tutto quanto più bello andiamo
a mettere noi
o si scosti così bollenti una nota da
quello bossi spargiamo col dorso di un
cucchiaio sì o sì
mamma mia quando poi si scioglie sopra
senza paure senza rancori senza remore
cui ogni a questo punto su quello li
mettiamo dei mirtilli su quello di una
fragolina taglia tina e su questo qui
mettiamo dei lamponi all'impiedi tft e
vi è chi è questo qui è il risultato
finale ragazzi lo trovo delizioso veloce
veloce tra i dieci minuti mi inizia
fisico da covip
per chi non lo sapesse ancora dal lunedì
al sabato alle 17 in line su instagram
guglielmo scilla il programma
d'allenamento più seguite in italia
detto ciò direi che è arrivato il
momento di passare all'assaggio come
sempre ragazzi taggate mitch vista gravi
se farete questa ricetta ma guarda io li
amo pitrolo stupendi iscrivetevi a
questo canale mettete un pollice in su
scrivete anche a benedetta grazie mille
benedetta per averci fatto avere questa
ricetta e fatemi sapere pure quali sono
altre ricette che vorreste vedere
altissimo purissimo io non so come
allenerò con questo suo stomaco combo
lamponi imbarazza
mamma mia ma un'altra prova un'altra
cosa rispetto a quelli americani sono
fammi provare uno con i martini del no
raga fra volerebbe in bra di tutti
non so voi sempre preferito credo
lamponi bomba senatore ramponi ragazzi e
provate lì se li fate taggate mi sono
una cazzata in realtà mi raccomando
mantenete bene a neve gli albumi e
lasciate che il lievito faccio la magia
[Musica]
ciao ciao